there was one shot in the movie that was
so to me so emotionally moving you
talked all about making the tiger
realistic when the weight and the walks
and the and everything but the shot that
I heard that was so moving to me was the
shot where Richard Parker's fallen
overboard and he's hanging on by his
nails to the boat at night and you know
it's how it looks over and sees him and
he looks at him and the look on the
Tigers face you can see desperation and
panic but beneath that is still this
dignity in this strength of a noble
character it's one of those moments in
the movie where where you're most
tempted to start looking at reference
that has nothing to do with the tiger
and and and get away from the
animalistic qualities that we needed to
put in there less is more you know we
were trying to quiver lips and to you
know do all that so the fancy stuff but
at the end of the day we found some good
reference online of a scared tiger we
stuck to that reference and weed out the
performance back as much as we could and
we were really just you know a
disciplined with that until you saw your
own emotions reflected in his eyes it
was we're sort of converged on the claws
it's actually we spent a long time
figuring out exactly where to converge
that shot it's a it's tricky not so much
for the emotion of the shot itself we
want to have it fairly far for but it's
tricky because there are foreground
elements in the shot it's a it's a
fairly deep shot and because he's
reaching up and then there's the edge of
the boat that's all closer to you than
the Tigers face we couldn't bring them
too far forward and then you have to
consider the shots on the other side of
it I forget if we might have done a
little move in that one too
one of the first indications that there
was going to be something cool added
back was when we went out in that Coast
Guard Cutter and I'm looking at these
giant swells and I have a 2d camera and
I'm taking all these pictures and I see
this great wave scape at to snap a
picture and I look at the the frame and
the view and the little screen there it
looks very unimpressive because you lose
unless you catch them just right you
lose a lot of the depths it's like I
don't know how many golfers are here but
you watch the Masters and they're saying
oh look at the undulations and it's just
not there in the screen but that was
something that's a that's a subtlety
that the 3d gave back and it really
helped showing the waves and you know
getting you know we wanted to show what
it's like to be stuck there on the ocean
in the middle of these wave troughs and
you get all that back with 3d that was
something that was really cool story for
me first is what's most important the
way the process we did it I think you
lose maybe a little bit of it since you
know the weights him added it he edited
in 3d from like the beginning you know
our process kind of showed that you know
maybe we lose a little bit out of that
but I'm you know that's kind of where's
your mojo take over and I think you have
to pay a little more attention to the
detail because of the fact that it picks
up the subtleties in motion that you
don't normally have to worry about as
much every every kind of motion we had
any any of the ships or anything like
that as precisely as we could do it
would certainly help their process when
I first got on this movie I just thought
that this you know there's no faith
there's no big actor in this movie there
was no and I kind of imagined that it
would just be like a small little tiny
movie that and it just kept on like
getting bigger and bigger and bigger and
bigger and bigger this as well I need to
keep son so I was I was kind of magic
would do a tank and we would go on the
ocean for some shots and I just thought
we'd just go do this in a really kind of
small way and you know every time I said
well this equals this the disciples this
and this equals this equals walls going
this high and then to see where we went
from what my initial kind of thing I was
thinking about and initially to what we
all kind of generated this whole thought
I think it's amazing I mean I just think
where we are on the tank and just to put
a boat in the tank and then you see in
the world that we did I you know I look
at back of them I got you know and I you
know I went to die diddle in another
movie whether we're still doing VFX and
I came back and then just had tons of
surprises of like you know seeing the
Edit finally together and seeing not
just the you know the edit with you know
the previous Compson and it was just you
know and I saw Bill's work and it's just
like wow that you know I was always
worried about that the tiger is it gonna
be real enough here you be and that was
kind of my base
initial worry in the very beginning of
the movie and I remember like Oh God
just tiger you know you know it's gotta
be and then it was like you see the
tiger and you see the textures and his
eyes and it was one shot I said when he
looked underneath the cover and you see
his eyes and and then bill did so much
detail and the eyes actually put the
reflection of of Pi looking at him in
the reflection so it's not just like a
camera flexion you just that much detail
that you know anyway I was just kind of
blown away so I just I love those kind
of surprises
every creative ambition that Aang had
led to a technical challenge but every
technical solution led to actually then
stimulated the creativity again that
there was a real back-and-forth that
that you know when we started to see
things that they could do that actually
fed in names animation I'd been used to
doing a lot of this fast paced action
movies where it's cut cut cut here comes
big thing flying in her face and then
explosion you know I really learned how
to sort of slow things down you know
he's a master like timing things so you
feel a motion from what you're doing so
I think that's that's probably one of
the biggest things I'll take away along
with using stereo to enhance that sort
of thing when I first heard that it was
gonna be 3d movie at it like Brad was
saying the first thing I think of is a
car tumbling towards me you know and
stuff like that and that and it was so
nice to work on a show where you
realized that the the subtleties that
you can do that you can hand over to
bill that makes it into art is the thing
that I learned the most have made it it
just is so nice to see something happen
like that
the thing that I'm taking away most and
Ben asked us recently they asked things
like should you do post conversion or
shoot it natively and you know there's
technical discussions of that I think
what really goes into a good 3d
experience is exactly what Tim described
it's the filmmaker embracing the process
it's if you conceive the film as a 3d
movie and you embrace it that way you're
gonna have a great 3d experience it's
not really whether you post converted if
you post converted and you just need a
2d movie it's not gonna be as satisfying
so if you're gonna make a 3d movie make
a 3d movie and think about the process
all the way through whether your post
converting or shooting a native we've
done sort of build a little bit of a
reputation on doing photorealistic
animals and we've done it for a lot of
movies but then these things were
perfectly calmed and shadowed and
reflected and and fur blowing in the
wind staff all purr and then they would
jump up and start dancing or talking and
for me it was just a lot of fun to just
finally you know just get a character
that that could stay animalistic
throughout and that we could really sell
as as photorealistic and I was that was
pretty awesome